thanks Yasser the view from the capital
but also with a very special guest we
have uh Gary in the house Gary you've
made the first move for a magnum spot I
have to say Magnus is not really in
great shape today no the the game where
I made the first movie won
I'm not responsible for the rest yes
that's it you know it's all downhill
from there yes
so not um not very impressive not very
impressive since it's let's say the game
this game is shaky yeah it's the I don't
know why but
how do you because you know it's very
difficult to turn it around
um but how do you do it when you have
a slow start in a blitz tournament
using my memory I don't know that
definitely Magnus Magnus should know
better than I do I still think that's
that's where we haven't seen the rest of
Magnus but
as of now it's um yeah it's old is it
about the confidence it's about the
preparation what do you think is lacking
in the first three rounds
Blitz is not so much about preparation I
think it's more it's more about more
about confidence and definitely is
confidence
is not what used to be so it was there
and um but
with Magnus you you should always expect
you know
something to happen he can always turn
it around
um it's uh versus Magnus
kept your Rook on D5 you know what's
this earlier earlier oh yeah here yeah
but why not Rook D5 maybe even go Rook
D5 yeah that's the best move in the
position oh my goodness
she does this yeah oh no that's that's
this is bad yeah the Fuji takes are free
I think 395 Bishop B3 and then therefore
such a comfortable position yeah
yeah
amazing they may not go for it how do we
assess this one
no it's a probably it's equal now
because he just sees Rook C6 Rook A6 yes
it's the the problem is it's the uh yeah
um
the problem is this is Obi-Wan you
prevent The Rook from getting to a file
so it's a bit tricky now or maybe you
started with Rook C6 now do you still
have the opportunity to go Rook D5 at
any point
it's not because
yeah okay he just did that yeah
um
still the same I would probably down the
distance in different order okay we go
A4
but that's that's why I thought you know
Magnus had to do it more just you know
it's here yeah it's a rook D1 I would
have played Rook C6 immediately first
yeah because of through the 188 would be
one
I have King C7 yes
yes
and you're not worried about the king
size no but it's dead then then a 40K 60
you cannot do long Bishop D1 so that's
why yeah that's a very good point yeah
yeah exactly yes so that's the
um
a small detail but definitely makes a
big difference in this one this is the
game yeah yeah that's evil A4 you see
that's the yeah okay
this guy's truck by the way how are we
doing all the time 135 yeah
I mean if Max wants to make a draw I
think because A5 should be a draw but
it's the A5 and b67 what is that Bishop
D7 just you know keeping
cool
but
but he doesn't want to make it wrong no
it means some victories right he's like
some victory three and a half points
well he's maybe dreaming about I don't
know how he
was even if he's porn he ends up on H4
which is not you know automatic that's
what he has in mind now H5 H4 yeah
that's a block so let's say we make some
moves H5 H4 but then then this is
totally paralyzed I still don't see how
you can you can make progress but you
know maybe bishop b6iv
but paralyzing this this year first here
so that's the key and he's going for it
yeah yeah that's right yeah
of course H5 so I guess he played Bishop
to C2 so that Rook D1 Rook D5 Bishop
Bishop E6 Bishop E6 you don't want to go
Rook D5 now because that's not a good uh
Rudy what he played yes Bishop B6
Bishop B6
wow
rugby one and now B6
only chance I didn't play for something
you play B6
problems with B6 you know
maybe he plays H4 now of the B6 H4
just star Stars just to finger H1 yeah
this created H3 Maybe
this is what Magnus also wants to see
just some imbalance
take some chances
but he understands how dangerous B6
because the rules
but it was Rook on A6
it takes time for Rook to come back yeah
I mean in theory if he does it if
nothing happens The Rook B6 now let's
test this is
but he just definitely paralyzes he
spawns there so is this H4 but I see no
maybe you can bring the king somehow to
A5 but then I bring the king okay
exactly yes yeah yeah this is over yeah
should we move to a different one let's
see maybe we have some more oh my
goodness what this is uh Wesley versus
Aguirre
Gary's last move was Rook to see what
takes place
he took something what is he okay
yeah it's winning results
not winning no no that was that's what
we have that's it Ah that's it it's over
Shake offense
yes
but after losing such as lousy Game 12
years now he's just yeah he did he did
something very spectacular he's
definitely uh Bogdan might be getting
his first Victory
um in the blitz portion actually perhaps
against Richie
and by the way what about time
well bogged down with his usual seven
seconds against them
good enough
Bishop C4 okay
it's not that easy anymore right
B5 I think he might have missed this one
made that move with two seconds Bishop
D2
can I go H5 each one
that's what you'll do now
before
yeah five
yep oh rookie six
okay
Bishop D5 probably has to be which Bay
eight
Magnus did draw his game against
voitashek nothing unexpected
too Bishop B1 good move
perhaps a move missed by rapport
Duda is still playing but right now Rook
F6 yes amazing
horse the trade but that's not good news
that's bad news yes now
is feeling it
you still don't have absolutely any
counter players black
F3 we exchange that King F4
A7
I think we're going to see a resignation
yep resignation wow
big victory for the young Romanian and
the last game pending is uh Duda versus
chefchenko chefchenko versus
control
the draw
seems like a
like a bedroom
seems like that that's a good thing yes
that's the best way to put it now it's
just
wow
chefchenko is still flying is there a
way to to do anything here no G5 at some
point
no just it doesn't matter yeah G5 you
always stay with the pawn
as long as Don was the B4 Pawn it's
it's over
yeah they're looking at each other
Shaker fans draw
Gary exciting chess so this is always
exciting yeah what can I say it was
always exciting yeah so but by the inner
world it's it's it's a good tournament
it's what makes me feel really good is
that the the branches to concept
has proved it's a
um it's
um
usefulness yeah and it establishes place
in the in the world of Chess and we had
some ups and downs but now we're on a
solid pass to expand uh our reach so
it's uh oh it's always um
yeah
solid to have two uh two um foundations
which is One Foundation but it's it's
two you may say it's two two legs uh in
America and in Europe and um actually
omega's suggestion that some may could
find a bit far-fetching uh spoke to the
Polish organizers we're very proud some
of the some of the minor sponsors of the
event who joined to us a little bit but
locals uh polish companies and they were
very impressed with the event and I said
look it's a somehow it's a you know you
have an interesting um a reference or
reminiscences of geopolitics so we have
in granchester the Coalition similar to
the College of willing helping Ukraine
we have America Poland Romania and
Croatia yeah so there's no Hungary
so yeah it's in chess so it's it's uh
again it's it's of course it's a stretch
I understand but still you know we just
as they say in every coincidence there
is element of coincidence and I have to
say Gary a very inspired wild card we
lost the world champion ding one week
before this event but Levon is doing
just an amazing job yeah absolutely it's
just that's that's that's it improves
the old chess uh rule that you know
always watch the Players and invite the
last minute no chance to prepare but
definitely bringing his hunger to this
time that's a rabbit and blades and live
on this you know it's a seasoned season
fighter so but but then he plays fresh
chess and I like his games yeah so it
says F4 these are very this that's like
old-fashioned players yeah some
feel the romance of United States which
is one more question for you Gary before
we throw it back to the studio when you
are getting ready to make the move for
Magnus Magnus wasn't there and Wesley
told you come to my book no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no he said
take my Lucy play
you didn't want to trade
we'll leave it for next time
thank you very much for joining us
appreciate it guys back to you in the
studio